the deliberating is over yeah just
sitting down here yeah Gareth Southgate
has settled on his England squad for
Qatar dreams broken for some but shock
selections too adding creativity and
attacking options at the World Cup
James Madison is in from the cold after
three years Marcus rashford returns for
the first time since last year's Euro's
final defeat
do you feel that you have to take
England back to another final goal one
stage further would it be a letdown not
achieving that well whatever happens
this will have been the second best
period in English football we've got the
chance to make it the best we would love
to take the country on another Journey
like we did in 2018 in the Summer where
they were throwing beer over each other
and like we did for the Euros at home
they're chasing glory in Qatar but
there's unease about doing so in a
country where migrant workers have
suffered and same-sex relations are
criminalized FIFA asked teams not to
moralize and lecture particularly around
this tournament were you and the players
continue to speak out in Qatar I don't
think we'll stop doing that in fact we
won't stop doing that
um
how much we can affect and how much
influence we will ultimately have it's
difficult to tell England have also been
seeking change from social media
companies after the racist abuse black
players faced after the penalty shootout
defeat to Italy I would always advise
players not to use social media too
regularly but
that's the world they live in you know
they're young people and young people
live a lot of their life via social
media so
um as long as you can rationalize that
and not let it affect your happiness and
your mood then that that's fine six
years into the job Gareth Southgate is
still up for the challenge of ending a
56-year trophy drought for the three
lines
is this your last shot it's glory
whatever in anything with England I have
no idea I mean I'm I'm looking forward
to it it's at the lucelle stadium on
December the 18th where England will
hope to lift the World Cup Rob Harris
Sky News Saint George's Park